these are provocative images likely to
stir anger in Hong Kong not calm
concerns the site of well-known
pro-democracy activists behind the bars
of a police car will alarm those who
fear the authorities are fast running
out of patience and employing ever more
controversial tactics to quell the
protests Joshua Wong and Agnes Chow both
still just 22 are well known to the
authorities as student leaders of the
protests in 2014 if they're nervous
about the personal implications it
didn't seem to dim their determination
we Hong Kong people won't give up and
won't be scared by these white terror
and injustice but we will keep on
fighting for democracy we shall not
surrender and I urge international
communities could send a clear message
to President Xi sending troops or using
emergency ordinance is not the way out
we spoke to Joshua Wong a few hours
after his arrest and court appearance
and he warned the crackdown could be
putting protesters into violence I don't
advocate of thousands I understand the
reason for people use force to protect
themselves and that's the reason why
Fung corners have sympathy on them he
was spotted speaking to us and
immediately drew calls of support and
defiance from passers-by Hong Kong has
been gripped by weeks of protests some
of them violent with water cannon being
used by the police for the first time
last weekend whilst protesters responded
by lobbing Molotov cocktails the rally
planned for this weekend has been banned
but the arrested activist insists people
are ready to defy that you think the
approaches will go ahead despite them
being bad people will still get her on
Hong Kong Island too
show that women we must know sign us our
voice under the crackdown of human
rights on Thursday Chinese troops were
seen on the streets of Hong Kong with
the china people's liberation army
suggesting it was just a routine
rotation of troops in its Hong Kong
Garrison's the move came as once again
riot police were seen performing
exercises in the Chinese city of
Shenzhen which borders Hong Kong the
timing of these maneuvers has been
viewed as a deliberate warning that
Beijing is at the very least threatening
to deploy armed forces in the city for
the first time the huge demonstrations
have plundered Hong Kong into its worst
political crisis in decades sparked by
the government's plan for an extradition
law which would have sent criminal
suspects to China for the first time the
arrests of such prominent activists and
frankly young people who many view as
civilian heroes around these parts is
likely to incensed Hong Kongers who are
bracing themselves for further violence
over the next few days the international
community will be looking on to see just
how the authorities and more importantly
how Beijing responds Alex Crawford Sky
News Hong Kong